but i agree with you dude i'm i i'm not
a spiritual guy
but i believe in energy because you know
the basketball right now is the to me
if you don't believe in energy just
watch basketball right now
and listen to those guys talk about the
ener they feed off the crowd
they the energy they feel from all of
those people it
when you walk into a stadium a home like
a football field
and the game's going well you can feel
the comedy club right
you can feel it so you can feel it it's
like
you know those bees kill the other
animals
it's like that that that you can it's
it's visceral
yeah and you feed off without a doubt
and so how would you quantitate that or
how would you describe that
you know what i'm saying like a
scientist came in it's like well what's
going on here like when you get to the
comedy store
if you do you know the helium or
wherever you know in portland and
it's a sold out crowd and you walk in
you just you can
feel the vibration of human bodies like
it's this
weird negative energy too but also
dude like
negative energy too but also dude like
we've all been around getting up at the
moment who worked i get up at five
give them five of them they have a
different there's something about them
there's a different energy there's an
aura there's
yeah there's this weird energy like oh
yeah and everybody listening you've been
in a room where someone's walked in
or what and you're like dark energy it
could be a dark or something but you can
kind of feel sort of heavy
i believe in energy dude and so i i i've
had the conversation we
look i'm jewish beth is catholic uh
jacob went to uh uh uh temple israel for
preschool but we put him in notre dame
for high school sure because i wanted
i wanted him to take his he can choose
for his own like it's not up to me
what he's going to believe but when they
ask me what i believe
i believe what you'd believe which is
we're energy and when our
body leaves i think sometimes the energy
sticks around
that's that's just what i think we're
all i think that's yeah that's how i
feel it yeah i agree
that's how i try to describe that kid as
a nightmare do you believe in ghosts
i don't know it's not that i don't but i
don't know
do you think it more more because
rogan made a good point with post malone
he goes
ghosts won't just show up during scary
times when it's dark outside like we've
never seen a ghost on the beach
well you've never seen a ghost like you
know like in the club like why would
they just avoid clubs
here's what you want to hear my theory
on that you know such a good point you
don't think there's a ghost in the club
no one's ever seen it there's no no
picture it's always this spooky house
like
those only decide to stay in these
creepy ass areas i'll tell you that's
cause of movies right that's because
that's
we associated like movies paint such a
dramatic picture for everything
so it's like daylight i mean i think so
i think like why isn't a ghost at a
football game
because the comedy show i here's what i
think
first i think um harder to see the ghost
in daylight that's that's not a i don't
know
that yeah that looks like the bird [ __ ]
on the window like i don't know it's
true but i think harder to see ghost in
the daylight
but i also just believe man that
uh you believe it but like bad beings i
believe in bad and people
i believe in bad and good i re i really
i cuz i believe in
energy right so i believe that sometimes
bad energy gets left behind i think it
just all stays
here on earth no sometimes it goes
somewhere else
no when the energy's gone i think it's
gone oh wow so when you when
life well no then you don't believe in
ghosts dude i believe in
that so say you die a man right yep and
but your energy
stays here did you just fart no i was
tapping on wood i thought you gave me
i don't want to die what's the what is
the word tapping on wood dude it's like
a good luck thing you don't want tap you
know
knock on wood knock on wood yeah yeah
but knock but attack foot
yeah but but but what did you do i don't
want to die okay i'm like if you die
driving home by the way i don't believe
it but just in case you know what i mean
like yeah
i don't even know if i believe that but
yeah but i believe that sometimes man
like
the energy stays and and until it's done
until it burns out that's why i think
ghosts end up
like stuck do this doing the same thing
yeah
because that's kind of what they're i'm
gonna tell you a story that you may or
may not believe
you're gonna tell me a ghost story right
now i'm gonna tell you one you may and i
may not believe it okay
all right now what be careful because i
was on ghost adventure with zach baggins
so i know my share of ghosts okay okay
all right all right i'm gonna tell you
when you may or may not play
and i for sure uh
i'm sure i'll get a couple of toasty
comments yep
yep i mean rightfully so though you know
yeah man and by the way i don't give a
[ __ ] yeah but i mean what are you gonna
do
so i did a show for facebook
this year called josh wolfe's wonderful
world of weird i got a leech put on my
[ __ ]
i got oh dude it was a banana for
medical reasons
uh that's what they said but i just did
it for the show i ate
uh bull dick soup uh i i went all in
right
did you travel all over the world for
this or all in los angeles oh wow
all in los angeles we went down this
hotel in downtown l.a
and i believe in energy but i've never
really come across go so i've never
really experienced it
sure so we're in this hotel and um
one of the rooms they just can't
was just disheveled and they were like
well we'll send you up to this whatever
that room was
and and i go why this room they said
well we can't rent it out
because people always ask to leave that
room because weird [ __ ] happens in it
so you walk in it's got upside down
furniture nobody's been in there and
but there's two separate rooms in this
hotel room so we walk into this one room
and it's
kind of chilly and i'm like huh i walk
in but nothing's happening we walk into
the other room it's noticeably warmer
i'm talking to the ghost expert he's
telling me [ __ ] and i don't know how
much i believe it you know i'm leaning
into the show a little bit just because
you're trying to get entertainment right
we walk back into the first room
and we're finishing up the the shoot for
that room
and we all hear some music and i'm like
you guys hear that music and there was a
little radio
like an old-timey radio that was playing
just this old country music
love it and it wasn't on by the way when
we walked in
on now so i'm like the crew's [ __ ]
with me yeah okay
and the guy the ghost guy goes i said he
said
i think the guy in here likes music the
ghost that's in here and i'm like yeah
whatever
and he and i said let's just so we can
finish up the shoot let me just unplug
it
so i unplug it now when i unplug it it
before it turned off it got louder which
is i'm like whatever maybe it's just an
old radio
and uh we finished up the shoot and the
guy says to me
hey plug it back in don't keep it
unplugged for this guy
he likes he goes he likes music i plug
it back in
different station so different music not
country anymore
and louder interesting just plugging it
in plugging it out
radio turn it on by itself now i was
like wha
i'm the first one with the radio being
on
i didn't have eyes on everything yeah
[ __ ] happened i'm still i'm the one who
unplugged and plugged the radio
that is weird and so i it's one of those
things that's
when something is not i can't explain it
yeah you can't chalk it up dude it's
hard for me do you hear about that one
lady downtown oh yeah i already know
you're talking about do you know what i
mean you know what i'm talking about
what are you talking about
yeah the water tank the water tanks the
creepiest one of the creepiest that's
that's the creepiness
story in l.a it's a it is a hotel your
channel stressed out it was a
hotel downtown l.a and she went missing
they have her on the elevator
terrified terrified she goes missing
they find her
in a water tank but this water tank they
had detectives and investigators
like there's no way into this there's no
there's no way to get into this water
how the [ __ ] did she die i mean there's
no way
into there's no like you would there's
this the way the water tank works it's
not like
she could climb in and dr like there's
no there's no
logic yeah so she they have her
some surveillance video elisa lam
yeah she was bizarre so they there's
she's just terrified here
and then she then they're scared of
something terrified
look at her pressing all the buttons on
that one road down
and the elevator door doesn't want to
close either
and then just watch watch her and you
freak out why is she pressing all of
those buttons no one knows
but she keeps looking like you know like
something's chasing her yeah
and she's like oh [ __ ] oh yeah that look
out the door right there dude is eight
year old
she's hiding for some look at her what
the [ __ ] man
and they never solved this nope no so
they never water tower
inside the watchtower that they can't
figure out how a human could get into it
they're saying it's too heavy for her to
like open it and how come
how big is this like is it like like
like one of those old-timey things that
they used to keep the water in for yeah
it's an old building cecilia big cecilia
hotel you know and it took
like a machine to pry it open and look
in there
and why isn't the associator moving yet
i know that's what's creepy and then she
just does this weird stuff
and so there's no video from when she
gets out of the
elevator that is i mean i don't think so
but
crazy that weird yeah man
her hands up or now how about that when
i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler we got a [ __ ]
together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son